ايضا الى هذا الخبر
العاجل الذي يظهر على شاشتنا قائد المنطقه
الجنوبيه بالجيش يقول ان التحقيق يجري
بالتعاون مع المصريين وما زال في بدايته
ونرحب بضيوفنا
نرحب بضيفنا من القاهره
اللواء الدكتور نصر سالم الخبير العسكري
ورئيس جهاز الاستطلاع بالقوات المصريه
سابقا
مما ينشره الاعلام الاسرائيلي ومما صدر من
بيان من المتحدث العسكري المصري ما هو
تصورك لما جرى اليوم
بالنسبه لما جرى اليوم طبعا
البيان الاعلان المتحدث العسكري انا اثق
في في صدق وتماما لانه ليس هناك ما نخفيه
يعني الجندي المسؤول عن الامن بيطارد احد
المهربين فحدث هذا الاشتباك وده وارد انه
يحدث مثل هذا الخطا تماما انه هو في اثناء
المهمه من على الجانب الاخر ذنوا انه
يشتبك معهم فاشتبكوا معه فتم تبادل
الاطلاق النيران يعني هذه مهمه وهذا
الجندي ينفذ مهمته او رجل الامن هذا ينفذ
مهمته طبقا للتكليف اللي هو واقف في
منطقته بيحميها بيمنع اي عمل تهريب يعني
انا طبعا الروايه او طبقا لما ذكروا
المتحدث العسكري هذا هذه حقيقه يجب ان
نقتنع بها تماما
ولماذا لا يكون مثلا لديه اهداف اخرى
سليمان خاطر وايمن حسب يعني هنالك الحوادث
السابقه لماذا يتم استبعاد هذا هذا هذا
الكلام سابق سابق لاوانه نحن الان امام
حدث او حادث محدد له افعال تمت ولو
ملابسات لا يجب ان
نسرف في التحليلات حتى يتم التحقيق هناك
تحقيقاتك كامله تتم على الجانب المصري
وعلى الجانب الاخر
واكيد الحقائق تظهر فلا داعي للاصراع بما
هو تفسيرات قد تخطئ وقد تصيب فلماذا لن
يفيدنا الان ان نسرع في تفسيرات قد تكون
خاطئه قد لا يكون لها اساس وقد تكون صحيحه
كل هذا الكلام يعني ارى انه متعجل الان
طالما ان الاحداث كلها محصوره هناك
اجراءات تحقيق كامله بتتم على كلا
الجانبين واكيد هي ساعات هتظهر الحقائق
الجاليه واي حقائق هتظهر هتعلن على الفور
لان ليس هناك ما نخفيه او ما يخفيه اي
جانب من الجانبين طالما ان هناك
حادث لا هو مدبر ولا خطا وارد تماما
وبتحدث في اي دوله من الدول حوادث حدوديه
ممكن تحدث فارى ان يتم
الانتظار حتى تصدر او تنتهي التحقيقات
وتظهر الحقائق الجاليه يعني في اللغه
المستخدمه في بيان المتحدث العسكري تحدث
عن عن وفاه وليس استشهاد فرض التامين
المصري عاده ما من يموت في الواجب
وفق وفق المصطلح العسكريه يكونوا شهيدا هل
هنالك اي تفسير لذلك
يعني التفسير ان هذا الجندي حتى
يعني نضع
صدر
الشهاده من عدمه هذا هو انها حاله وفاه لا
التحقيقات لم تنتهي هل هناك خطا هل هناك
اعمال يعني نقول
يعني غير مفهومه حتى الان فكل هذه كما
ذكرت يعني مش عايزين نتعجل لو انتظرنا
هتظهر الحقائق الجاليه دون اي اجتهادات
وزون اي ارهاصات قد تخطي وقد تصيب فيما
يتعلق بمساله مطارده
مهربي مخدرات كيف وانت خبير عسكري كيف
تفسر لنا انه لا يوجد اي شيء عن اي اصابات
في صفوف تجار المخدرات او اين هم او اين
ذهبوا بينما هنالك اصابات بالصدر والراس
في صفوف الجن ود الاسرائيلي
يعني اي ربما لان قبل هذا عندما يتم
اشتباكات مع مهربين قد لا تعلن مثل هذه
الحوادث اللي كبر الموضوع ودخله في دائره
الاعلام بالشكل ده ان هناك على الطرف
الاخر هناك جنود الاسرائيليون هذا هو
السبب في ظهور هذه الصوره بالشكل الذي
يتناوله الاعلام
وكما قلت اننا لا نريد ان نتعجل قليلا من
الوقت تظهر الحقائق وسوف تعلن لي الروايه
الاسرائيليه تقول انه ان هذه عمليه
تخريبيه وان هذا الجندي مخرب
لماذا لم يرد الجانب المصري على كلمه
التخريب هذه يعني هذه كلمه كبيره ان تطلق
على جندي مصري
يعني هذا الموضوع المتحدث العسكري رد عليه
وذكر الحقائق جاليه
ونحن لنا ان ناخذ بما قاله المتحدث
العسكري اما ما يذكره المتحدث او الجانب
الاسرائيلي فهذا شانه ولا افسر ما يقولونه
لنا ان نفسر او نتكلم عما اعلنه المتحدث
الرسمي او المتحدث العسكري المصري فيما
يتعلق بالروايه الاسرائيليه ايضا
تقول انها عمليه وعمليه تخريبيه اذا ثبت
ان هذا عمل سواء بدافع وطني او باي دافع
اخر ليس له علاقه فقط بالمخدرات وتهريب
المخدرات كيف سيكون انعكاس على العلاقات
بين الجانبين
العلاقات بين الدول لا تحكمها اخطاء فرديه
اذا كان هناك خطا فردي سوف يحاسب طبقا
للقانون وطبقا للعرف
يعني ليست يعني حادثه ناتجه عن خطا فردي
ممكن ان تعكر صف علاقه بين دولتين جارتين
باي شكل من الاشكال هناك تحقيقات تتم
وبناء على هذه التحقيقات لكل مقام المقام
فيما يتعلق باستعاده جثمان هذا الجند ما
هي الاجراءات في مثل هذه الحالات هل سبق
وان كانت هنالك حاله مشابهه ان يكون جندي
مصري في يعني يلقى حتفه داخل الجانب
الاسرائيلي من الحدود ما هي السوابق
السابقه وكيف يتم التعامل معها
يعني ليست في امام الان حوادث محدده ولكن
اعتقد ان الجثمان سوف يعود يعني طبقا
للاعراف الدوليه وطبقا للقانون الدولي
والعلاقه التي تربط دول الجوار ليس هناك
شيء يعني غير طبيعي ما حدث وحادث فردي
وسوف يطبق فيه القانون والعرف الدولي بكل
حذافيره ولا اعتقد ان الموضوع يعني في
اجتهادات او
تاويل لهذا الحادث اللواء نصر سالم فيما
يتعلق بهذه المنطقه المنطقه جيم
وافقت تعديلات 21 عام 21 ما هو المسموح
بوجوده في هذه المنطقه من معدات ومن قوات
القوات اللي موجوده قوات امن عاديه موجوده
بالتسليحها الشخصي
وطبقا للاتفاقيه ليس هناك اي مخالفه على
الاطلاق
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور ناصر سالم الخبير
العسكري رئيس جهاز الاستطلاع بالقوات
المسلحه المصريه السابقا